on the 11th of december 1936 a man spoke
on the bbc millions of listeners held
their breath as he announced his resolve
to go forward with
a decision which was and remains unique
in british history
his abdication of the throne that man
was edward viii
the reason behind his abdication was his
love for a woman the british court and
the establishment would have never
accepted as queen
the american twice divorced wallace
simpson in today's biographics we're
going to present their story one of
frustration unhappy marriages and
fraught relationships
the story of how a man and a woman
renounced the british crown
apparently for love and of how they were
tempted to reclaim the throne by the
machinations of their supposed enemy
the third reich
[Music]
edward was born on the 23rd of june 1894
in richmond surrey he was the eldest
child of the future king george v
the grandchild to king edward vii and a
great grandchild of queen victoria who
was still alive at the time of his birth
he was always known in the family as
david the last
of his many middle names from his youth
edward was set on a naval career however
the quick ascension to the throne of his
father george v
in 1910 meant that edward was
immediately appointed prince of wales
on his 16th birthday edward had to quit
his naval studies and enrolled at oxford
it's generally agreed that edward was
intellectually underwhelming or maybe
just not that interested in studying
besides a good performance with his polo
team at oxford
he had little academic achievements and
left university after
eight terms with no degree at the
outbreak of world war one edward joined
the grenadier guards the
young prince was keen to see action on
the western front like his rival
counterpart and relative german crown
prince wilhelm however the british
government
forbade this for risk of losing the heir
to the throne
after the war in january 1919 edward's
youngest brother the prince john died at
age
13. after a long struggle with epilepsy
the young prince had succumbed to a
seizure
on this occasion edward referred to
john's death as little more than
a regrettable nuisance his contacts with
john were so limited due to his illness
that he remembered him as
more of an animal than anything else
edward had to write a letter to his
mother apologizing for being such a
cold-hearted and unsympathetic swine
throughout the 1920s edward undertook
extensive foreign tours particularly
in the british empire representing his
father edward also took to visiting
areas of high unemployment and
deprivation in britain during the
economic depression of the early 1930s
these occasions made him familiar and
popular with the press
and the public his image at this stage
was that of a dashing dandy good-looking
well-dressed skilled at playing polo and
flying airplanes he had earned a pilot's
license in 1918 and was the first
british monarch to
ever fly an aircraft in the 1920s edward
also dedicated time to
another passion he had a string of
affairs with several married women which
cemented his status as the world's most
desirable bachelor at the same time his
affairs seem to
keep him from fulfilling one of his
duties as prince of wales
finding a suitable match in late 1930
edward had started a relationship with
thelma viscountess
furness also married at the time it was
thelma who probably in january 1931
introduced him to
a beautiful intelligent and witty
american friend wallace simpson
[Music]
wallace simpson was born bessie wallace
warfield on the 19th of june 1896 in
blue ridge summit pennsylvania this is a
spa town where
her father ticol wallace was seeking
treatment for tuberculosis which
unfortunately claimed his life when
messi was only a few months old bessie's
mother was an impoverished widow but
fortunately she was taken in by solomon
her
late husband's rich brother living in
baltimore solomon also paid for bessie
wallace's education as an exclusive
all-girl private school as a teenager in
baltimore wallace dropped the betty and
was subjected to many girlhood passions
she fell madly in love with two teachers
and
several girlfriends and sent them
letters describing them as beautiful
little partridges
there is no proof that she actually had
any homosexual relationships though
after graduating wallace dated many
handsome men despite not being
well off nor especially good looking by
the standards of that time
in 1916 wallace married an airman called
wynne spencer the marriage
it was not a happy one though when wynn
tried to kiss her on their wedding night
wallace
recoiled later she asserted that the
marriage was never consummated
this marriage it was really doomed to
failure wind was transferred to china
where their relationship eventually
broke down because of wind alcoholism
and sadism wallace left the household
and went to live with her friend
catherine and her husband hermann rogers
hermann was
not just a friend though wallace
considered him to be the true love of
her life
however according to her biographer
andrew morton this relationship also
never evolved into a sexual one
later she met a south american man
felipe espel who
also undoubtedly became the true love of
wallace's life though
she never definitively had sex with him
either wallace then moved to england
where she married anglo-american
businessman ernest simpson ernest may
not
have shared wind's alcoholism nor sadism
but also this second marriage was
a platonic relationship again this is
wallace's own version as reported by
morton in london wallace became friends
with thelma viscountess fernes who
introduced her to edward from then on
wallace became a regular presence of the
royal social scene and she
started to receive letters signed simply
pw
for prince of wales
when the affair between thelma and the
prince of wales came to an end wallace
took her friend's place
very early in the relationship wallace
became indispensable to his household
she organized his dinner parties and
went on exotic foreign holidays with him
royal courtiers were not openly hostile
at this stage yet
they were wary of wallace's hold on the
prince again evidence suggests that
their relationship was not of physical
nature and there are questions about the
true nature of their attraction but
edward soon
had to face reality on the 29th of
january 1936
george vi died after a prolonged illness
it was time
for his accession to the throne the new
king did not have any intention to
interrupt his love story with wallace
and the two continued to be seen
together at
official occasions such as the
proclamation of his own accession
at this stage their affair was not
widely known to the public as the
british establishment did their best to
hush up the whole story but members of
high society had started spreading
stories which
made their way to the u.s and other
countries readers abroad started to
collect
news clippings from gossip columns and
post them to relatives in the uk
in other cases foreign magazines
carrying the news were sold in london
an article from the milwaukee journal
dated the 30th of october 1936
tells of how american newspapers were
mysteriously removed from newsstands in
central london sometimes just a
selection of pages
had been ripped out after a while the
whole world seemed to be in on the story
except for the british press who
feigned ignorance or just chose to
ignore the affair when wallace finally
divorced her husband it meant that she
and edward were
one step closer to marrying but this was
covered by a single article at the
bottom of page 10
in the guardian the story of the affair
between the king and a twice divorced
american
finally exploded in december of 1936
when bishop
blunt of bradford denounced the couple
from his pulpit
with the cat out of the bag and with
wallace's divorce out of the way
a word started to make the rounds
amongst the british cabinet of ministers
and that word was abdication as king of
great britain and northern ireland
edward was also the head of the church
of england
at that time the church did not allow
for divorce people to remarry
unless their former spouse was already
dead so could the head of the anglican
faith violate one of the tenets for
his own church for this reason the
cabinet feared the british people would
never accept wallace as queen
edwards had to choose either wallace or
the crown
but actually at the beginning he tried
to negotiate with the cabinet he had
already proposed the idea of a morgan
attic marriage to prime minister baldwin
in
november of 1936. a morganatic marriage
would leave edward on the throne
assigned to wallace a
lesser title instead of queen and would
have revoked the rights of succession to
any offspring when baldwin rejected the
proposal edward had only one option left
on the 10th of december 1936 king edward
viii submitted his abdication to the
government
which was endorsed by parliament on the
very next day he had become the only
british monarch to ever resign
voluntarily his brother
albert duke of york would rise to the
throne as king george vi
on the 11th of december the now former
king announced his decision to the
nation on the radio
a few hours ago
i discharged my last duty as
king and emperor and now
that i have been succeeded by my brother
the duke of york my first words
must be to declare my allegiance to him
this i do with all my heart
you all know the reasons which has
have impelled me to renounce the throne
but i want you to understand that in
making up my mind
i did not forget the country
or the empire which as
prince of wales and lately as king
i have for 25 years
tried to fail but you must
believe me when i tell you
that i have found it impossible to carry
the heavy burden of
and to discharge my duties as kings
as i would wish to do without the help
and support of the woman i
love and i want you to know
that the decision i have made
has been mine and mine alone
this was a thing i had to judge
entirely for myself the honor
person most nearly concerned
has tried up to the last
to persuade me to take
a different cause this part was true
although
at the time few believed edward's words
wallace was horrified at the idea that
edward would advocate for her and tried
to talk him out of it
there's only been an affair and not real
love wallace was still in love with
felipe and with hermann but once the
abdication
was announced she felt obliged to go
through with the charade and mary edward
now styled the duke of windsor
biographer andrew morton reveals that
on the day of the wedding she begged
herman her one true love
to get her pregnant this would not have
been possible as a previous surgical
operation had left wallace in
capable of conceiving in any case
hermann refused her proposal edward and
wallace married on the 3rd of june 1937
at the chateau de carnes near
tor in france a guardian article from
that time reports that herman rodgers
was much present at the ceremony
he played host to the groom walked
wallace to the altar and even delivered
an
address to the press on behalf of edward
asking for the couple's privacy to be
respected based on what we know today
about
wallace and herman the whole wedding
must have felt incredibly awkward
for these two souls in any case the
marriage it was sealed and the newlyweds
left for a three-month honeymoon
in austria yet again based on morton's
accounts also wallace's third marriage
remained unconsummated
[Music]
for the following two years wallace and
edwards or the windsors lived mainly in
france the relationships between them
and the royal family were
severely strained edward was furious at
george vi
for refusing to star wallace as her
royal highness on the other hand george
forbade his brother to return to britain
lest he rescind his generous allowance
the relationship with the court
and with the cabinet worsened when the
windsors visited germany in october of
1937. the official reason for the visit
was
for edward to learn more about the
regime's employment and housing policies
in truth edward was craving a princely
treatment especially for wallace and
knew that the german leadership were all
too keen to roll out the red carpet in
addition to that he
saw himself as a mediator between
britain and germany
during their visit the windsors met with
gerring foreign minister ribentrop
goebbels himmler and rudolf hess they
even spent two hours with the fuhrer and
the duke was photographed delivering a
nazi salute
the british government they saw this as
a bit of an embarrassment
two years after the declaration of war
on germany edward was appointed liaison
officer to the french army when the
germans finally invaded in may of 1940
the windsors escaped to southern france
and then they went on to neutral spain
and
finally to portugal in july new prime
minister winston churchill was keen to
get the windsors back to britain as soon
as possible but the duke delayed
proceedings as he wanted to negotiate a
post befitting to
his rank and simple courtesies for
wallace meanwhile the germans were
conspiring to get a hold of the windsors
in their plan should the invasion of
britain succeed edward would have made
a good collaborationist king their
theory was confirmed by the intelligence
reports flying in from madrid and lisbon
according to which
windsor spoke strongly against churchill
and against this war
and that the duke was convinced that had
he remained on the throne
war would have been avoided and
describes himself as a firm supporter
of peaceful compromise with germany the
telegram from lisbon continued with a
sinister note the duke believes with
certainty that continued heavy bombing
will make
england ready for peace a certain show
about the royal family builds on this
idea that
edward may have inspired the carpet
bombing of civilian targets in britain
this has not been verified and surely
the luftwaffe did not need this passing
comment to
inspire their strategic plans what we
can say with more certainty though is
that edward was potentially pro-nazi
and still believed in the 1930s politics
of appeasement
and was a defeatist to say the least
churchill was aware of the danger of the
duke's declarations and so issued orders
to keep an eye on him lest
he speak against the allied war effort
to the press he even
sent him a direct warning ordering him
not to mention any view about the war or
about the germans or about hitlerism
which is different from that adopted by
the british nation
and parliament but the duke's delaying
tactics they continued
churchill's ultimate solution was to get
the duke as far away from europe as
possible by
appointing him governor of the bahamas
but edward
refused claiming the bahamas to be a
third class british colony and
consider returning to spain as franco's
guest instead
von ribentrop took advantage of the
stalling situation and sent an explicit
offer to the windsors
germany is determined to force england
to peace by every means of power and
upon this happening would
be prepared to accommodate any desire
expressed by the duke especially
with a view to the assumption of the
english throne by the duke and duchess
the offer did not solicit an immediate
agreement but neither a flat-out
rejection a german agent reported that
the duchess appeared to be considering
this
proposal very thoughtfully but this was
not enough for berlin
the germans needed to take the windsors
back to madrid to better control them
and
so they launched a secret operation
codenamed willie to
ensure that the duke bent to their will
the head of nazi counterintelligence
walter
schellenberg traveled to lisbon to
oversee the simple plan
it involved a threatening message
relayed by miguel primo de rivera a
spanish nationalist very close to franco
de rivera
informed the windsors that they had
uncovered a british plot to
murder them and urged them to seek
spain's protection
eventually plan willie failed winston
churchill threatened the duke with a
court-martial if he refused to accept
the post in the bahamas edward was after
all a major general of the army and
subject to military justice the windsors
eventually left for the bahamas on the
1st of august 1940. the duke may still
have been wary of the warnings from de
rivera so he demanded protection from
scotland yard
edward had been physically removed from
the war in europe but he still managed
to score more embarrassing situations in
late 1940 for example when interviewed
by an american magazine he said
there will be no revolution in germany
and it would be a tragic thing for the
world
if hitler were to be overthrown hitler
is the right and logical leader of the
german people
hitler is a very great man as a governor
of the bahamas edward disliked the job
but
he did some good work there the duke
launched initiatives to raise wages for
bahamians and
promoted plans to relieve poverty but
true to character he could not help
yet another faux pas as he addressed
these social problems he blamed them on
men of central european jewish descent
who had secured jobs as a pretext for
obtaining a deferment of draft
full reports on the whole relationship
between the windsors and nazi germany
were collected after the war in the
so-called windsophile most of it however
remains classified and for the moment
we will not know the full extent of the
duke's sympathy or even collaboration
with the regime
what we have are his public declarations
and his interviews in the 1950s he
blamed world war ii on
anti-appeasement politicians in britain
roosevelt
and the jews in 1966 he told an american
newspaper he believed the uk
should not have intervened he stated i
thought the rest of us could be fence
sitters while the nazis and the reds
slogged it out and privately he
expressed the view that i never thought
hitler
was such a bad chap after the war the
windsors lived between the u.s and
france on the outside it appeared as if
wallace and the former king
lived a happy life of leisure thanks to
the allowance that was still granted to
them but the reality was not as it
seemed as
andrew morton has uncovered by reviewing
wallace's letters
edward was always besotted completely
infatuated with her
wallace always treated him with
deference and respect at least in public
she always referred to him as the duke
and called him sir in public but in
private things were very different
she spent her days being unpleasant to
all those around her and treated them
with harsh coldness especially her
husband to
whom she denied any intimate contact he
would often say to her am i going to bed
in tears again tonight
according to morton all they shared in
later life was
a mutual interest in golf fascism and
casual racism wallace never forgot her
first true loves for felipe but
also for hermann many of the letters
uncovered by morton
in fact are addressed to him when
hermann and felipe died wallace was
devastated and she retreated from the
world paying
little attention to her husband edward
paid only short visits to britain
after the war mainly to attend funerals
of family members his relationship with
the royal family remains strained and
distant his health deteriorated and in
the early 1970s edward was diagnosed
with throat cancer
during his dying moment on the 28th of
may 1972
the former king was being comforted by a
nurse with his last breath
he whispered wallace wallace and wallace
but wallace was not there edward died in
the arms of a stranger rather
than the woman for whom he had abdicated
after the duke's death wallace settled
in paris
once a known socialite described as one
of the best dressed women in the world
wallace retreated from the world and
stopped entertaining she died of
coronary heart disease on the 24th of
april 1986.
without any heirs nor relatives she left
her estate to the pasteur
research institute
and so ends one of the saddest personal
stories of the 20th century
as wallace and edward's lives have been
told on film many times i'm not going to
ask you to suggest a cast for
yet another biopic film but rather
ask you to consider this considering
what we know about edward's
pro-appeasement and potentially pro-nazi
stance
what would have happened if he had not
abdicated could an extended reign of
edward viii have changed the course of
history how would have world war ii
played out in such a scenario well
please post your
alternate histories in the comments and
as usual
thank you for watching